hi Matt here with a quick request we'd
love your help and guidance we've
created a short survey on LinkedIn to
get your input on areas you'd like to
learn more about take a minute to visit
our think fast talk smart LinkedIn page
to complete our brief survey while there
please also follow us you can follow us
on Instagram as well
finally for those of you who listen on
Spotify we are loving your responses to
our episode specific questions keep them
coming as always you can learn more at
faster smarter.io where you'll find
quick tip videos our newsletter English
language learning materials and
information about my new book think
faster talk smarter
hi Matt here I'm amazed that we are
today celebrating our 100th anniversary
episode a huge thank you to all of you
our listeners we appreciate your support
your input and your passion to hone and
improve communication skills without
further Ado let's get to it
welcome to think fast talk smart the
podcast I'm Matt Abrahams and I teach
strategic communication at Stanford
Graduate School of Business I can think
of no better way to celebrate our 100th
anniversary than by inviting back our
very first guests from way back in
January 2020 my good friends and
collaborators Adam Tobin and Dan Klein
and add to the mix and provide her
expertise we've asked Patricia Ryan
Madsen to join us as well as a quick
introduction Adam Tobin is a senior
lecturer in film and media studies and
also teaches in continuing studies at
Stanford Dan Klein is a lecturer at the
GSB and theater and performance studies
and also as an instructor at the
Stanford design school Patricia Ryan
Madsen is Professor emerita from the
Stanford drama department and is the
author of The Amazing book improv wisdom
don't prepare just show up
welcome to all three of you you are all
such wonderful improvisers teachers and
just people in general I am so excited
and honored that you're all here to help
us both celebrate and learn shall we get
started yes let's do it all right well
Dan and Adam it is great to once again
be huddled around a microphone with both
of you I gave you some homework for
today and you graciously accepted I
asked each of you to listen back to our
first episode and I'm really curious
what are some key takeaways or ideas
that you found most intriguing and why
Adam how about we start with you sure I
was really struck with the ingredients
that the three of us came up with at the
end kind of spoke to this overall
power and philosophy of improv which is
to say
how do you show up how do you create a
space that is safe enough for you to
then get lost a little bit and hopefully
your audience too and explore right so a
lot of what people are looking for is
how do I communicate better but really
what improv does is it trains you in how
to be safe
almost wherever you are constructing
with your listener and partners
a way to communicate that allows you to
play and discover a little bit so that
was the real takeaway was you're
building a safe space and you're trying
to do that almost in every communication
so it's that collaboration that you have
with your listener and building that
space where it feels comfortable to be
who you are all of those things the
collaboration the listening the presence
saying yes to things makes you a
different kind of powerful a different
kind of invulnerable because no matter
what comes your way your philosophy is
I'm gonna integrate that I'm going to
take that in and then all of that
empowering your partner and your
listener allows you and them to play to
discover something to risk that was
really what I was thinking about was
it's almost like how do you create a
safe space to get lost in ah interesting
right so you feel comfortable with that
being uncomfortable yeah
so Dan what was the takeaway you had
from our last conversation so long ago
you know listening back to it the thing
that jumped out at me was I love the
story Adam that you told about about
driving up to the city and getting lost
every time and then realizing at some
point wait I'm still lost but I've been
lost here before and I know how I can
get out of this and that was a
breakthrough and then the next level of
the Breakthrough was talking to Patricia
and Patricia saying oh no it goes beyond
that it's actually getting lost is the
point like get what we can get out of
being lost and enjoy that and so I think
that goes the whole thing that you were
saying the metaphor of being lost as
being something exciting and Powerful in
a place that you can actually embrace is
really the essence of what we're talking
about and it's finding A New Path not to
break the Paradigm or something but just
to discover to learn to enlarge your
world view for many people listening
that can sound really daunting to take
that leap of faith that which you'll get
there but with the three of you here as
our guides I think it's really really
insightful for people to think about how
they can build that trust and that
collaboration and Patricia it's
wonderful to add your voice to this
conversation Adam and I have taught a
class together for over a decade and he
tells that story every time and I am so
thrilled to have you here to elaborate
on the part of the story where he says
and Patricia says I should seek out
getting lost and so thank you for being
here it's a pleasure I would love to
hear a little more detail about why
getting lost is so powerful and then I'd
love for you to spend a moment talking
about your book improv wisdom I am not
joking that book fundamentally changed
my life Adam introduced it to me and
still to this day employ some of the
learnings from that book so once you
talk to us about being lost I'd love for
you to pick one or two of the key
learnings from there and share those
with us
seems to me that getting
lopping the the kind of mind that looks
at whatever is happening and accepts it
there's a fundamental acceptance of Life
of other people of whatever is going on
that's built into the whole yes mind of
Improv
and I think what is customary is to make
a judgment about whatever is going on I
like it I don't like it I agree with it
I don't agree with it yeah yeah yeah
there's a yes no in every relationship
to what life brings us
and the notion of getting lost is an
openness of willingness to
see whatever it is and work with it
doesn't mean I'll necessarily like it
but it means that I'm not going to use
the mind of no
which is very common and very useful we
need the mind of no from time to time
but if we start working on what happens
to our experience when we open to things
and we work on acceptance rather than
some kind of political view if that
makes sense sure absolutely so it's this
notion of being
open and agile rather than sitting in a
place of trying to put your point of
view out there on top of it right and
that's a message that comes through in
your book for sure will you highlight
one of your maxims that you give they're
so helpful and easily implementable in
some ways thank you well I think one
that's important is just show up just
show up is about the power of your body
in motion and that very often we start
with the notion that we need to decide
or think something through very
carefully before we take any steps
so the improviser's Mind suggests step
first and then see where you are it's
very different ready fire aim uh-huh so
showing up or getting your body there is
an important part I make it's important
in our life too if we want to for
example get an exercise regimen going
you show up at the swimming pool or at
the gym
show up where the things happen that you
need to be
so showing up I think is an important
one we recently had an episode with
Katie Milkman who studies how to incent
ourselves to achieve the things that
we're talking about and she talks a lot
about these internal hurdles that we put
in front of ourselves that get in the
way of showing up right and I think you
are reminding all of us that
the way to show up is to take that first
step and that's really important for all
of us to think about because we have all
this stuff going on on our heads that
prevent us from taking that first step
I'd like you to Patricia share one more
item from your book that you and I have
talked about subsequent to that yeah a
lot of us feel like we're always being
judged and evaluate and and you tell a
story if you wouldn't mind sharing where
you were out to do a reading at a
Stanford graduation yes and something
happened there that you had to respond
to and you have a very interesting take
would you mind sharing that story with
us be happy too it was one of the most
prestigious moments of my life I had
been invited to the I was going to say
coronation
of the new University present and I was
to give a reading from The Works of Jane
Stanford my dramatic reading was
following an orchestral
selection that had been composed just
for this auspicious event I was
listening and the musicians came to a
kind of a soft
Crescendo closing and I stood up and I
walked to the microphone and opened my
book and said and now the words of Jane
Stanford and then right at that moment
the music continued to the second
movement of the piece began
and oh was it clear that I had made
total humiliation but what can you do so
I took a breath and I sat back down and
I listened and I thought I should really
listen to this music better and the
interesting thing was when the music did
conclude I got up and I opened the book
and said and now the words of Jane
Stanford there's this lovely Ripple of
laughter through the audience that they
really understood that my world didn't
fall apart right it also reminds me of
Dan in the last time we spoke on this
podcast talked about you know aim for
average and cheer super average failed
cheerfully failed cheerfully that was
fail tearfully yeah and it said to the
audience we don't have to worry about
Patricia she'll be fine yes yeah and we
can return to the words of
Jane Stanford right and you did
everything by by letting go of your ego
or humiliation and just returning to the
task at hand cheerfully right so at all
of that just dissipate yeah and that's
what I took away from that is that you
were able to not get locked up in the
judging and evaluation of others you
were just present and did the job that
you needed to do and I think that's
really important the greatest moment was
that moment when I began again with the
smile and we were all together and you
created a shared experience out of
something that went awry right right
I want to pick up on something Patricia
said because when we were together
before Dan and Adam we didn't really
talk about non-verbal Presence at all
but Patricia talks about stepping in
yeah to action and and there's a lot
that goes on in our bodies in our voices
that impacts how we show up
and I thought what might be fun for us
to do is there's an improv game that is
called gibberish translator would the
three of you be willing to play this
game for us yes I'm sure
and then I'd love to have a discussion
of it because I think this opens up a
whole bunch about nonverbal presence so
I'm arbitrarily going to pick Adam to be
our translator and Adam is a very
talented individual not only does he
speak English fluently but he happens to
speak two versions of gibberish very
well that's right and and Dan speaks one
version in only one version of gibberish
and Patricia happens to speak another
and what I'm going to ask Patricia and
Dan to do is to have a conversation and
Adam is going to act as our intermediary
he's going to help all of us
non-gibberish speakers understand what
Dan and Patricia are talking about so
with that Dan can I ask you to start our
conversation and then Adam will help us
Translate
foreign
welcome I'm very happy to see you and I
have a number of questions about the
opening of various flowers
I am so pleased you asked me that it's
my favorite yeah
my favorite too but let's get to it do
flowers think
they think deeply very deeply
ah excellent that was so much fun to
watch it in real time so thank you to
each of you I would love to deconstruct
this for the listeners what was going on
because I think Adam you did a great job
of imposing a conversation where there
really was none it was just gibberish
but before I get to Adam's point of view
Patrician Dan can you share for me what
you were thinking about as you entered
into this conversation you knew you were
going to be speaking in gibberish yeah
what was going through your head when
you initially started what I was really
trying to do was give Adam some emotion
and some Rhythm so that he would have
some anchor to connect to if I just did
a monotone then he has to make it up out
of nothing and so I wanted to give him a
little something so I hope I was able to
do that that was at the start I think as
somebody listening and not participating
I think you did serve up some things
that Adam jumped on and I want to hear
what he heard but there's a lesson I
think in what you just said is that you
were trying to assist your listener Adam
to be successful you were making an
offer as I've heard many of you speak
about Patricia was there anything you
were thinking about as you initiated
this interesting I wasn't thinking at
all in fact I love this game especially
getting to be the gibberish part of it
because I don't need to think of what
I'm saying and then translate it into
gibberish I need to utter something with
some kind of an emotion or a feeling
yeah so what I was going for was the
sound of answering a question
and leaving the specifics to the
translator so you you came from a place
of emotion and you knew that the way you
said something the way you inflected
your voice would also be an offer that
absolutely yeah that's right one of the
main ways we can communicate right and
do all the time yeah in fact when we say
oh this is the best day of my life we
people don't believe the words we said
they believe the emotion with which we
said it yeah absolutely So Adam what
were you doing to translate you were
getting lots of offers from both sides
what were you what were you doing I was
trying to hang on to anything they were
putting out there and as Dan said and as
Patricia said they put a lot out there
there was variation in tone there was
speed there was emotional inflection not
just a question or a statement but the
kind of feeling that they were going on
and that was wonderful Adam and I teach
a class together and we will sometimes
use this as a vehicle to help people
understand vocal Express oppression and
how we can use our voices now what
people couldn't see because this is a
podcast was you were also with your
bodies making offers so Dan looked
inquisitive and Patricia looked knowing
and through our bodies and voices we're
conveying lots of information I want to
make this very real for those listening
in we have experts at improv playing
improv games improv games are fun and
they can teach you lessons but I think
what we just did translates really
nicely into small talk and chit chat you
walk into a space you don't know people
you throw something out there a question
or an insight and then if it goes well
people take that so what you just
demonstrated and the ideas you talked
about I think translate really nicely
into a very common speaking situation
that many people feel uncomfortable with
and that's the Insight in the unlock
that I think improv can bring is we can
take these and I don't mean offense by
this but silly games and then we can
take from the really meaningful things
that can help us so can we just quickly
go around the room here what Insight do
you have or advice do you have for small
talk I get this question all the time
how can I be better at small talk I
always speak gibberish
my tip for small talk would find
something that you notice about someone
else in the room instead of trying to
say something interesting about yourself
or what you've just done if there's a
way in which you can engage
the other people or find some something
to comment on about what they're doing
or what they've just said or where
they've come from that if you can
deflect off of yourself onto the other
people in the room I think it it can be
really helpful where we get stuck is
trying to come off as masterful with
small talk or something like that but if
you're interested in others there's
always something to say I've got a new
habit now practicing this when I'm out
in the store or being checked out by a
grocery person or somewhere besides
saying thank you for bagging my
groceries I'll try to point out
something I'll ask a question like how
long have you been standing on your feet
oh my gosh how do you do that do you
ever get to sit on a stool or something
and and I've I've found that if I engage
even strangers with a curious question
it often lightens up their day so I
heard two things you said there Patricia
I think are really important one is
Observe and notice something in the
moment and in the environment and
comment on that and the other is be
interested if Rachel Greenwald who is on
our show has this wonderful saying in
small talk it's important to be
interested not interesting yes and I
think that's a really powerful way to
look at it thank you great quote I just
learned something that's a great one
Patricia the idea of like pointing out
something in the even if it's fairly
innocuous like that's a red shirt like
that may start a thing and that's all
you need you just need something to be
started be interested and follow the
Insight that I was going to give yeah is
I like to be in the mode when it's
working the best is eliciting stuff
stories rather than asking for
information try to get stories I learned
this many years ago watching a good
friend at a summer camp and every time
we would sit down at a table with guests
she would get them talking and she had a
go-to which was always how did you guys
meet
and that's simply an invitation for a
story and it works with anyone it
doesn't have to be a romantic couple it
could be any pair of people or Trio how
did you guys meet instead of where are
you from what's something interesting
about your hometown that only a local
would know and of course I think last
time we even talked about the story of
your name yeah as a great way to rather
than what's your name why are you called
what you're called how did you get that
so seeking story is really a fun way and
telling stories is a little easier for
us when you ask somebody it's something
we can do that's great what I love about
this is I think the easy advice I've
heard is ask questions which comes from
a position of putting your partner first
and noticing things but this goes beyond
a kind of robotic ask questions about
the other person and it really is be
interested find that person's story and
dig deeper in that way without crossing
any particular lines but most people
want to talk about themselves yeah and
it's something that they know and
something they're more comfortable
talking about
I'd like to turn our conversation to
some topics that I know you all have
some thoughts on I know that because
I've interviewed all of you before
especially for the book I've got coming
out and one of the things that I think
people find really ironic or confusing
is you can actually prepare to be
spontaneous and in fact it's to your
benefit to prepare to be spontaneous in
some ways I'd love to just hear thoughts
about preparing to be spontaneous
let me start on this because the
subtitle of my book improv wisdom don't
prepare just show up right I often need
to have a disclaimer because that's not
exactly true what I really mean to say
but was too long for a subtitle was go
ahead prepare all you want spend a lot
of time preparing do it a hundred
different ways and then set it aside and
then show up yes so that there's some
way in which preparation isn't the enemy
but it often gets in the way when we
show up of actually being there fully
and noticing what is happening and who
else is in the room you have a saying in
your book about it your preference for a
surgeon would you share with us oh sure
yes I think that fits right here yeah I
want a surgeon who has passed all the
exams and is the top top guy who knows
everything there is to know about
replacing my hip
but also if something goes a little awry
I really hope they're an improviser I
hope that they're able to look at the
situation not from a formulaic point of
view but with fresh eyes oh we all need
to do that we can't live by the formulas
although they're often very very useful
right and I think that's a great way to
capture this notion of prepare but be
spontaneous because the surgeon should
know how to do surgery but in your case
he or she might have to do something
unique and different thoughts on
thoughts on preparing to be spontaneous
yeah I remember going into Patricia's
office 35 years ago when I was a TA for
beginning improv and we it was early in
the quarter we'd done several sessions
and I would get to see the plan for the
day she would say here's what we're
gonna do we would meet 15 20 minutes
earlier maybe half hour early and go
over the plan and then one time I came
in and I had just taken a class in San
Francisco I said oh I learned this great
exercise and without missing a beat but
you said let's do it I thought well what
and what ended up leading this exercise
she adapted the plan that was carefully
crafted and well thought out and put in
something brand new I still teach that
that exercise in the same spot in the in
the class now that we that we have and
that really changed my view entirely
prepare
and then be ready to go off script as
soon as there's an opportunity yeah it
gets back to what we talked about at the
beginning of this conversation which is
building up a trust in yourself right
right and so you do the preparation so
that you are expert in the material
and then you let go of the specific
delivery of the information in favor of
being aware of what's going on now
integrating present information is
something that gets cut off from people
who just prepare and read the script
that's right so it's all the preparation
all that work stops right when you're
about to deliver instead of
trusting that that stuff has been
internalized haven't you noticed that
someone delivering a prepared speech has
a whole different sound to the quality
of what they're saying than natural
human speech one of my former Stanford
improvisers Vince Ritchie his job is
helping right now Japanese students take
exams or interviews to get into U.S
colleges
and he went to an important conference
where these were all interviewers and he
said the single thing that they all
agreed that they hated the most was the
sound of a prepared answer
so very often when we're preparing for
an interview we'll think of ordinary
questions and then we will write them
out and memorize them but that it's not
that the answer is wrong but there's
something about reciting your
preparation that doesn't really sound as
human as we could be it feels
disingenuous and it's the exact opposite
from what we're trying to do we're
trying to look prepared and professional
and buttoned up yeah but there's there's
something that seems false about it and
what's false about it is it's not in the
present moment right it's a artifact of
work you did before I like to think
about what you all said as like an
athlete you know an athlete does a lot
of drills if you play soccer or you play
basketball you dribble around orange
cones a lot you're not doing that to get
good at dribbling around orange cones
you're doing that so in the game you
know how to dribble and you're gonna
have to adjust and adapt to what happens
in front of you the person isn't going
to stand still like a cone but that
preparation frees you up to be more
spontaneous in the moment so I want to
turn to the topic of listening over
these hundred episodes we've done one of
the things that has surprised me is how
important listening is and how
frequently it comes up as improvisers as
teachers I'd love to hear just your
thoughts on listening and if there are
any bits of advice or guidance you give
to help people listen better Dan do you
want to start
sure I think it's 80 at least of the
work is the listening that's where all
the information is that's where all of
the stuff that you need is in the
listening one of the things that always
strikes me is the moment when we turn
self-conscious the moment we're thinking
oh how am I doing or what I'm gonna do
or what I just did is a moment we're
missing something and so don't beat
yourself up it's just a reminder to tune
in and pay attention because there's
something happening right now it's a
call to be present and it's a call to
pay attention yeah yeah and whatever is
going on becomes our food that we are
fed by not only the words but the body
language the thing we learned in the
gibberish game in watching the whole
presentation because it might not be the
content of what our partner is saying
but something about the way they're
saying it which leads us to a better
question or something new or New
Direction in a conversation popularly
people talk about reading the room right
and it's it's that sense improvisers get
of a almost peripheral awareness of the
things going on right in front of us and
then all the extra information that
we're trying to integrate the most
useful idea that I know about listening
I learned from Patricia which is the
windshield wipers which is really about
attention and that you know when other
things kind of cloud your attention your
brain is working and it's evolutionarily
trying to help you out in all these ways
and you kind of say thank you brain for
doing that work and then you just like
windshield wipers you gently move those
aside and it's clear path in front of
you and you rededicate your focus to the
person you're listening to or watching
or being aware of and then something
else will come up and the windshield
wipers will say thank you brain just
gently push that aside reassert
your attention I've done it a bunch of
times in this interview even what am I
going to say what am I going to say stop
it listen to Dan's Rich bass voice talk
about the listening
that visualization I think is very
helpful because I think a lot of us get
distracted and then we beat ourselves up
and we say all these negative things
like I wasn't paying attention or oh no
what do I say now let me just say thank
you brain I really really like that the
one thing I heard subtly being mentioned
by all of you is that listening is not
just hearing the words it's how the
words are said and also we have to
listen to ourselves the reaction we have
to those words so listening is not just
external it's internal as well
as I expected this has been absolutely
fantastic and we're going to change up a
little bit how we end this podcast
starting with this episode I had three
questions I asked every single person
all the time we're going to keep two of
those three in Dan and Adam since you
were so kind to answer those questions
previously I'm going to save two for
Patricia because we haven't heard her
answer but for the first question I
would like to play another improv game
and one of my favorite improv games that
Adam introduced me to was word at a time
so I'm going to ask the three of you to
give some advice that you would like
communicators to take with them but
instead of each of you telling us the
advice as a whole sentence you're each
going to contribute a word at a time and
I will attest to those listening they
have not practiced this they didn't know
this question is coming this is
spontaneity happening now Patricia is
our newest guest would you mind starting
always
keep Trucking when you're
truck
seems to
break down
ah very good advice it's not about
persistence tenacity and grit in
communication before I get to question
number two can we just quickly debrief
that because some of you had words that
weren't big words and others of you at
moments said words that really drove
this in a certain direction excuse the
pun talk to me about how it felt to say
the instead of Truckin I mean it took me
a while to get this to embody this
because when it when you're doing it you
think well I gotta get a good word I
hope it comes to me to get a good word
if in the rhythm of the sentence what
comes to you is not a big word it's the
or if or when or whatever that's what's
needed your job is not to say the good
word is to say the next word and after
playing it for years I've actually lost
track of whether or not I'm saying a
Content word or just like a glue word
yeah
it's just the next word yeah there's
such a powerful lesson in that I think
in meetings and in interactions we feel
like I've got to do a great job here and
sometimes the best thing you can do is
either say nothing or just paraphrase
what was said really powerful or just
listen yeah or just listen yeah Patricia
I'd like to come to you with our next
two questions if you don't mind okay oh
gosh who is a communicator that you
admire and why hmm I think in the past
few years
I've come to respect Barack Obama
greatly there's something about his
leadership and the way he spoke which
seemed to me natural and believable that
was something we needed in politics and
in the world so I think Obama would be a
person that I admire for his speech in
his communication skills absolutely
somebody others have mentioned and for
all the same reasons that you did last
question I'd like to ask what are the
first three ingredients that go into a
successful communication recipe Adam
said cinnamon last time so we know
cinnamon is needed trust yourself care
about the other person and have fun I
love it have fun trust yourself care
about the other person thank you thank
you all for joining me once again I'm
going to end the podcast in Adam since
you are such a great gibberish
translator I'd love it for you to
translate my ending into gibberish if
you don't mind would that be all right
fine summons well a huge thank you to
all of you for coming and joining us
Patricia Dan and Adam it was wonderful
to be back with some of you and to
include Patricia with us and the
concepts and ideas we talked about
trusting ourselves helping others
listening so critical and here's to
another 100 episodes I'd love to have
you back at 200 and with that thank you
to you and thank you to our listeners
and the seventh thing about Patricia Dan
Adam gunslingen and the loose nintendent
and the Flint into 100th episode
sneaky thanks for joining us for another
episode of think fast talk smart the
podcast from Stanford Graduate School of
Business this episode was produced by
Jenny Luna Ryan Campos and me Matt
Abrahams our music was provided by Floyd
Wonder for more information and episodes
find us on YouTube or wherever you get
your podcasts thank you and please make
sure to subscribe and follow us on
LinkedIn